- How are y'all?
- How are you?
- Good.
- I'm so, oh my God
you answered in sync in
unison, in, in unison.
That was amazing.
- We do that.
- We do that sometimes.
- We're- stop it.
- We're still doing it.
- So wait, I know we're all moms.
So are you looking forward to summer?
Like when kids beginning outta school
I'm looking forward to it so much.
- Yes.
- yes.
You know, what is, you
know, that morning rush,
right in that
that 45 minutes from
wake up to out the door.
- No matter what you planned,
somehow you're still in a rush.
Yes.
- And the packing of the lunch.
I hate the packing of the lunch.
- I'm lucky my daughter loves
to pack her own lunch. So,
- What?
- Yeah. She's very controlling about it.
Yeah.
- Wow.
- Anyway, I'm excited about summer.
Y'all do anything fun.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- We're doing, we're doing family trips.
- We have a big family trip.
- I love that.
Okay. We're doing a family trip too.
Um and it's just called at
my ranch the whole time.
- Oh.
- And I go,
I just wanna be on a four Wheeler and
I just wanna have so much fun.
I just wanna be-
- You're doing like a stay station.
- Yeah. Yeah. Well, I'm never there.
So like I'm here right now.
So I'm very excited about
it, but I, I don't know
if y'all feel this way, but
we're in a city, right.
A lot of the time. So
it's nice to get out.
Yes. That's why I like to do it.
Do y'all do that.
Do you like to get out?
- Yeah. Get into the nature.
- My family has a farm.
(Kelly laughing)
- I've heard it's called the nature.
- The nature.
- We get into the nature.
- My family has a farm in north Texas.
- Oh, what?
- Yes. Like where in north Texas.
- Okay. You take highway 287.
- Yep. I know. Oh my
God. You just said 287.
- Farmer Market road right?
- Oh my God.
- And it's like outside of
Wichita falls, about 400 acres.
- I have friends that went to
Wichita falls, like college.
- Yes. Midwestern state. What?
- Yeah.
- No, nobody.
No one, okay.
- Okay. (Kelly laughing and clapping)
- I love that 'cause we get out there
and the kids are like, "can we just run"?
And I'm like run.
- It's so cool.
- Go
- I love it.
Okay.
- See, she's learning so much.
- You gotta come to the farm.
- I know, I know.
- [Kelly] She loves the nature as well.
- I love the nature as well.
- Well, as working parents do y'all ever
do you have a hard time
at the balance of like
feeling like the guilt
of like not being home
but also you love work and you gotta work.
- It's always a balance.
I think for everybody, right?
- Yeah. I feel like
that's one of the things
we trade messages about all the time,
strategizing, strategizing how to be
where you need to be for work
and how to be home when
you need to be home
for the important stuff.
- Yeah.
- And many years ago I was working
on a new show called Splitting
Up Together and they,
they came to me and they
said I was gonna have to work
on Halloween, Halloween night.
- Yeah.
And my kids were little at the time.
Like Halloween was
everything to them, you know?
And, and for me too, I wanted
to put the costume on them.
- Yeah.
And take them around.
And I, they told me I was gonna miss it.
So I called Angela,
and I was just, oh, my
mom heart was breaking.
- Yeah.
And she
had an idea.
- Well I just said,
what are you doing Sunday?
Because I have it planned.
So I guess I told her
what she was doing Sunday.
I said, come over.
I talked to my neighbors
and I said
my friend's gonna maybe miss Halloween,
will you guys help me out?
My kids dressed up.
We dressed up in our costumes,
our neighbors
I got candy for everyone.
And her and her kids came over
in their costumes and we
trick or treated my street.
(audience clapping)
- Yeah.
- That's so nice.
- I know, two days early
She made a little Halloween for me
and her neighbors were the sweetest.
- My neighbors were so wonderful.
- But I mean, that's
the best friend right?
- That is a great friend, yeah.
- She saved Halloween.
- And it was, it was so sweet.
- Aww.
- And you're right though.
There are those like pivotal
moments when they're little
they love, they only like
that stuff for so long.
Right?
- Yeah.
It's only like so cool and fun so long.
You wanna, you don't wanna miss one.
- Yeah.
So I get that so nice.
- My neighbors are the best.
I have to say that.
- I was gonna say also your street.
Bravo.
- I know, good neighbors, good neighbors.
- So you had a lot of
Hollywood first together
on the office,
like first red carpet, right?
- Oh my gosh.
- Wait, what happened?
- It was a hot mess.
- Well, it was called, it
was called Paws for Style,
- like paws.
Meow.
- Oh, it was animal related.
- Yeah.
- Yes. It was for an animal charity.
And it was a fashion show
where the dogs wore the outfits.
- Yeah.
- So the dogs walked the red carpet
- I love that this was
your first red carpet.
- She invited me, she said,
Ang I got invited to a red carpet.
I was like, oh my gosh,
well I have to get an
outfit. I got so excited.
And I opened the card and a
little dog picture came out
like a dog picture in a sweater.
And I was like, what is this?
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, and then when we
walked the red carpet,
it was first of all
actually a wooden floor
- Cause there were accidents.
- 'cause the dogs tinkle.
- Yes.
So they needed a,
- it's smart.
- Right?
Yes. And um, and I brought my dog.
So the whole red carpet
I'm like holding a dog, which was, he was
- Well, it's fitting, right?
- Yes. But he was, he was like
too big to hold gracefully.
Yeah.
- He was like a medium sized dog.
- Ohh
- And when I got to the carpet,
- there he is,
- There he is, look at me. I'm
like holding my dog on this.
- Yeah.
- Red carpet.
- It was awesome. I love
that you brought your dog.
- We did our own hair and makeup.
I went and got my outfit.
I got two turquoise tank tops.
Cuz that's what you do.
One at target.
And I got one at The
Gap and I layered them
- And I layered them cuz I,
- Oh, hey
yeah.
- So it's a little,
- Angela's holding two purses
because I was like, hold my purse.
I have to pick up the dog.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
- So, she's got two purses.
- It looks like, you're
in like in a purse ad.
- And I'm wearing,
- I'm wearing my mom's shoes,
which were a size too big.
So I had to do that thing with
my toes where you hang on.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my gosh.
So wait, you guys created rules
for award shows and events.
So what are your rules?
- Oh yes.
- This is in our book.
- Yeah. We're very excited about this.
Okay.
- Yeah. Actually a lot of
this, we, we kind of talk
about in our book, but we, we
kind of had to learn how to be
at these fancy shin digs together.
And so we came up with a bunch of rules.
One of them is eat,
- Definitely eat
- before you go.
- They don't feed you.
- there is no food there.
- And there's a lot of adult beverage.
- Food is important to me.
- And even when they have
food, sometimes I'm like
you're talking the whole time to people.
So you don't actually get to eat.
- Like everyone's like,
- You know what they're like,
they're like being at your wedding.
Like you're the bride.
And you, you do nothing
but take pictures and talk to people.
You never eat the food.
- Right
- But you'll drink a glass of wine.
- As it goes by.
- That's not good though.
- Problem
- in your empty stomach.
- Yeah.
- We've seen those people at award shows.
- We have.
- We might have been one of those people.
One time
- They're kind of fun
- Maybe one time
- Have you ever had any
wardrobe malfunctions?
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh. Yes.
- I did too. I've had one.
What was yours?
- Jenna's is really good.
- Okay. So at the 40
Year Old Virgin premiere.
- Yeah.
- Um, I had this dress.
It was a lace dress
that had like a turquoise slip underneath
and then I had a big sash
that came down the front.
- Yeah.
- And before I did the red
carpet, I had to use the restroom
and Angela said, "don't pee on the sash,
don't pee on the sash".
- I was so worried about the
sash going in the toilet.
- I had the sash up.
- Yeah
- And I rushed out to the red carpet
and when I got inside and
I took my seat, I was like
why do I feel so much
of the seat on my tush?
It was because I had tucked
the slip into my underwear.
Yeah. And if you, you look at that picture
you can see my Target undies.
- Yeah. Look
- You see the white spot.
- Oh
- Those are my Target undies.
- But here's the thing. It
just looked like a little
gold lace trim kind of
going on right there.
It didn't look like.
This, my favorite part is
you have no idea what's going
on and you're just like, check out my .
- They're like, over the shoulder.
And I'm like, you got it.
- They always yell that to me.
And I'm like, you over the shoulder.
- I say no. Yeah.
- It's not attractive.
I don't look good being
like, oh this is casual.
Like, it's like, no
- I was game.
I was like, sure over the shoulder
- I think that's early on.
I was game earlier.
And I'm just like, this is look yay.
Oh my God.
- That's what I do now
I say, I picked one pose.
This is the one pose I'm doing.
- Yeah.
- At least your boobs
didn't almost pop out.
- Your boobs almost popped out.
- My boobs almost popped out.
Hi mom
- Wait, wait,
what? When
- Okay. I got a fancy dress.
It was the year I finally,
someone gave me a dress.
I didn't have to go to the mall.
Yeah. Cause I did that a bunch of times.
So I, it had a train
and I didn't practice
walking with a train.
- Yeah.
- And so what happened was I stepped
on the train and then I stood up
and when I stood up, I was like,
why is my dress still down?
And I kept going like this.
And then that happened.
And then a bunch of people
snapped and I grabbed my boobs.
- First of all, you look gorgeous.
- Oh, thanks.
- And yeah.
I'm like, if they're falling
out or not, you look beautiful.
(audience laughing)
Is that, did your heel?
My stiletto gets caught in the lace.
Is that what happened?
- That's what happened?
- That happens to me all the time.
It happened to me yesterday on this show.
I literally always, I don't
know what I, I like play
with my feet down here.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Yeah. Well, but it happens.
- It happens.
And it's, it's a moment that
you'll live with forever.
- I wore a dress one time.
It was so close.
It was so tight.
Like it looked good.
And it was like, I don't
know, close after idol.
And I was like, oh, it looks so great.
And I was like, God, this is very fitted.
Right.
And I had to get a car
to like go whatever.
I had to lay.
I was laid down like just like
pretending like life was normal.
They had to like, somebody
had to like get me out of the
and then I like proceeded
to like mermaid walk down.
And I was like, this is not me.
What are we doing?
Anyway? You mentioned your new book
and it's about the office.
I love y'all so much.
This is so great.
So what made you wanna do this?
- Well, it started with
the spring cleaning
because I guess we're sort of hoarders.
- You are
- A little bit, we save everything.
You know, like if you go to movie
and you get the ticket stub or
- You save that?
- I save stub.
I had the,
- For what,
- Kindling?
- I had the ticket
- I don't know,
- Oh my God.
- I also save baskets
and Jenna saves old lamps
so that
- I'm convinced I'm gonna rewire them.
- Are y'all gonna like start
an antique mall business?
Like what
- I would love that?
- I love, I do love an antique mall.
- I love that.
- Yeah.
Well, so we had all this
stuff and we're like
what do we do with it?
We should do a scrapbook.
Or we should, you know,
- I mean we had thousands of pictures
from the office because
we brought our cameras.
- Old school.
- Like old school cameras.
- Yes.
- Yes. And so we started
compiling all of it and
and we were thinking about
stories we could tell.
And we really wanted to do
sort of a combination memoir
of our time on the office and
memoir of our best friendship
because that's where we met.
Yeah. And that's how
we became best friends.
And we had all these firsts
together and we navigated life
and motherhood and all
kinds of things together.
So we put it all in the book
and I think there's something
like 400 of our personal photos in there.
- Yeah.
- That is so cool.
And such great.
Like in, in, you know, behind
the scenes for fans, you know?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
It's such a cool thing that you did.
I'm so bad at taking pictures.
I literally, we celebrated
my son's birthday last night.
I, I think I took one picture.
Like I'm.
- Kelly, call us.
- I'm not, I'm
- come over and take pictures.
- I'm not good at it.
I'm not like a picture taker,
like my, myself or anyone.
I'm just like, I guess
in the moment, but it's
it's nice to live in the moment
but then I'm always sad
because I'm like, oh yeah.
What was that like?
And then I have no pictures, so.
- Well, you know what I
do right out of the gate.
I say, everyone, we're
getting a picture right now.
- Okay.
- And then we get it and then we have fun.
- Well especially cuz everyone
looks good in the beginning.
- That's right.
- That's exactly right.
- Then the night wears off.
- Yeah.
- Okay. So you've been
friends for almost 20 years.
That's amazing.
So yeah.
(Audience clapping)
What do you think,
what do you think
like the best part of your friendship?
Like I'm so glad that she was
there for me in this moment.
What, what's one of those moments?
- Oh man.
- Well, we talk about this in the book.
When I was in New York, once with Angela
we were doing press
for NBC for the office.
I fell down some stairs
and I fractured my back in four places.
- God.
- Yeah.
- And she is who rode
with me in the ambulance
to the hospital.
She held my hand
when I got a catheter.
- My favorite thing was the
nurse was like, would you
like your friend to step out
while we give you a catheter?
And she said, I'd like her
to stay and hold my hand.
- Oh my God, that's exactly
what I said in my head
- Don't leave me
- No,
- someone's about to do something to me.
- Stay right here.
- Yeah. But she advocated for
me with the doctors, you know
my family wasn't there
and she slept in a chair
in my hospital room
- And that's uncomfortable.
I've had to do that.
That's friendship.
That's love.
- Love.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping)
- That's, that's so sweet.
I love this friendship.
It's so nice.
Especially the chemistry
of that show is so great.
And that, even from that
you've got this beautiful
thing afterwards from it.
That's very cool.
We need another break, but
everybody, you gotta get this.
Jenna and Angela's book
is called The Office
BFF's tales of The Office
from two best friends
who were there
and it's out now.